[Música]
hoy 9 de agosto se celebra el día
internacional de los pueblos originarios
organizaciones como amnistía
internacional por ejemplo alertan sobre
la falta de protección en los derechos
de las comunidades indígenas que sufren
la falta de acceso a la identificación
la violencia institucional y la
expulsión de sus territorios el objetivo
principal de este día digamos es
promover espacios de encuentro
convivencia inclusiva y dinámica a
través del diálogo y la reflexión
saludamos a mirna con hija media es
activista indígena vicepresidenta del
fondo para el desarrollo de los pueblos
indígenas de américa latina y el caribe
de mirna buen día gracias por estar con
nosotros en directo américa de france 24
hablemos o por favor de la importancia
de nuestros pueblos originarios
muchas gracias por la invitación y por
recordar este día les saludo desde mi
región en la región autónoma de la costa
caribe norte de nicaragua en donde
también estamos conmemorando esta fecha
en el marco de la construcción de un
proceso de autonomía muy importante
definitivamente en los pueblos indígenas
somos más de 400 millones a nivel del
mundo más de 5000 distintos pueblos con
distintas culturas
mantenemos el 80 por ciento de la
biodiversidad del planeta está en
nuestros territorios y hablamos más de
cinco mil distintas lenguas o sea que
representamos un acervo cultural
importante para la humanidad pero creo
que lo más importante
raúl es el hecho de reconocer que
nuestros conocimientos tradicionales
pueden aportar muchísimo para enfrentar
las crisis que la humanidad está
enfrentando actualmente crisis climática
crisis de sistemas alimentarios en fin
nosotros creemos que el aporte nuestro
ha sido sustancioso hasta el momento
pero podemos más contribuir si se
reconocen plenamente nuestros derechos
eso le quería preguntar mirna es muy
cierto todo lo que usted está diciendo y
por qué entonces no cuentan con el
respeto de las instituciones de nuestros
gobiernos de américa latina y el caribe
tampoco el reconocimiento y digamos ese
pedido de ayuda a ustedes que son los
que más conocen digamos la naturaleza
de todos sus ancestros
definitivamente en américa latina hay
más de 17 países que reconocen
constitucionalmente a los pueblos
indígenas en muchos de estos países
también hay un reconocimiento al derecho
colectivo sobre nuestros territorios sin
embargo el modelo económico que se
impone en nuestra región prioriza el
extractivismo y el extractivismo
definitivamente significa que se extrae
de nuestros territorios los recursos y
generalmente sin participación de los
pueblos indígenas sin beneficiar a los
pueblos indígenas sin
la aplicación del consentimiento previo
libre e informado
entonces ese modelo económico realmente
choca con una tradición de desarrollo
para nosotros tenemos una relación muy
cercana con la naturaleza donde nosotros
realmente creemos que en la medida en
que estos recursos económicos se manejen
de una forma sostenible podemos asegurar
que sobreviven las siguientes
generaciones y no sólo nuestras además
tenemos que recordar que aquí se impuso
en nuestra región un modelo de
colonización que no nos reconoció así a
los pueblos indígenas se impusieron
sobre nuestros territorios las
repúblicas actuales y entonces todo el
marco legal y normativo
que se ha ido desarrollando a lo largo
de estos cinco siglos y medio realmente
lo que han hecho ha sido desconocer nos
entonces estamos nosotros en una etapa
en que hemos venido luchando fuertemente
para que los derechos individuales y
colectivos de nuestros pueblos se
inserten en estándares internacionales
humanos en las legislaciones nacionales
entonces creo que ese es la situación
que nosotros estamos enfrentando a pesar
de tener derechos reconocidos hay una
brecha enorme en la implementación
de estos derechos y esa es nuestra
demanda fundamental mirna y también que
nos estamos has dado cuenta cada vez más
a cada día más que este modelo que
estamos viviendo actualmente en nuestras
sociedades sobre todo después las
occidentales este modelo no es
sostenible no es amigable con el medio
ambiente estamos hablando precisamente
también de estos territorios o
protegidos territorios sagrados que más
allá de evidentemente ustedes tener de
necesitar además pues este
reconocimiento económico de lo que se
está extrayendo en las regiones que
ustedes protegen pues también está lo
que a todos nos concierne que es el
medio ambiente que es el planeta como
hace realmente para para protegernos
para que no sigan siendo vulnerados los
derechos de ustedes que son los mayores
guardianes de nuestras reservas
naturales
nosotros hemos tenido
una participación sostenida en todas las
negociaciones globales para abordar este
asunto y los planteamientos nuestros son
muy claros primero
reconocimiento pleno en nuestros
derechos individuales y colectivos como
pueblos esto significa el derecho a la
autodeterminación a la autonomía a
nuestra forma de gobernanza la
construcción de estados plurinacionales
multiétnicos en donde haya realmente una
complementariedad entre lo que el estado
actualmente en nuestros países con
nuestras formas de gobierno propio de
los pueblos indígenas en tercer lugar la
seguridad de la tenencia de nuestros
territorios y el control sobre nuestros
recursos
respeto reconocimiento y aplicación de
nuestros conocimientos tradicionales
conocimientos sobre salud sobre medio
ambiente
y obviamente si se logran estos
planteamientos vamos a poder entonces
trabajar en conjunto con los gobiernos
una propuesta de modelo económico que no
solo se aplique para nosotros sino para
todo el resto de ciudadanos ciudadana en
nuestro país es un modelo económico que
realmente respete la naturaleza y yo
creo que eso es el planteamiento nuestro
ahora hay mayor evidencia de que es real
porque el impacto el cambio climático
está afectando a todo el mundo